a cyber attack that knocked out several
government websites in ukraine on friday
is being seen as russia's digital shot
across the bow while the origins of the
attack have not yet been confirmed u.s
officials are warning that moscow is
sending signals and apparently following
a page from its own playbook as a
prelude to an invasion of ukraine troops
remain ready on both sides of the border
christina raffini has the very latest
from the white house this morning
christina good morning
good morning dana yeah these hacks come
just days after these negotiations
between russia u.s and europe and they
come on the heels of a warning from the
from the ukrainian ambassador to the u.s
saying that this could precede a larger
russian movement
when there isn't an actual crisis to
suit their needs
they'll make one up
u.s intelligence officials said
yesterday that in addition to about a
hundred thousand troops near ukraine's
eastern border russia has deployed
experts in explosives and urban warfare
capable of manufacturing an assault on
their own supporters we call a false
flag operation
an operation
designed to look like an attack on them
or russian-speaking people
in ukraine
again as an excuse
to go in an excuse the white house says
that could come in many forms including
disinformation russian influence actors
are already starting to fabricate
ukrainian provocations in state and
social media to justify a russian
intervention and so divisions in ukraine
and this week's high-profile talks
between the u.s russia and european
nations left american diplomats openly
unsure if russian participation was
little more than political cover there
was no commitment to de-escalation no
meanwhile yesterday hackers targeted
more than 70 ukrainian government
websites russian state actors are
suspected the culprit left an ominous
message
be afraid and expect the worst i think
what we're going to find is this is just
the beginning kris krebs former director
of the u.s cyber security agency whether
it's narrative building and propaganda
disinformation or technical attacks is
is just part of the tool kit that
virtually every every government is
going to use
from now going forward and again the
russians have been quite good at this
the white house said yesterday it send
advisors and i.t experts into ukraine to
help most of those websites however are
already back up online michelle
all right christine rothini thank you